طفله غير عاديه متاخره دراسيا ومتميزه
شعبيا تظهر على شاشات التلفاز وتضع احلاما
تجاريه كبرى ثم تتحول لشابه طموحه وقويه
تقف امام تحديات صحيه ونفسيه لتبدا مشروعا
ضخما وتبني ثروه تقدر بنحو 220 مليون
دولار انها الامريكيه العصاميه دانيال
بيرسون فما قصتها نشات دانيلا في مدينه
جاكسون فل بولايه فلوريدا مع عائلتها التي
تمتلك شركه لوكالات السيارات وامضى
الطفولتها مع شقيقتها التوام اليكس حيث
عرفت الطفلتان اجواء الشهره والعمل مبكرا
فظاهر تا في حملات الاعلانات والتسويق
للسيارات تميز الدانيلا اثناء طفولتها
بمهارات خاصه بالبيع وقامت فعلا ببيع
الاقراط في المدرسه وجنت نحو اربعين
دولارا اثناء الدراسه تلقت الي الكثير من
الثناءات لتفوقها المدرسي فيما كانت
دانيلا تسجل درجات منخفضه بسبب اصابتها
باضطراب فرط الحركه ونقص الانتباه ولذلك
كانت تكن احيانا بشق التوام الغبي عندما
بدات التوامتان رحله الدراسه الجامعيه
ذهبت كل منهما لجامعه مختلفه
فكانتسيلا في بوسطن انذاك كانت اليكس تطور
تطبيق سبين بوب الايجابيه لوسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي في مهمه دانيلا بمساعدتها قبل
ان تفكر ببدء شيئا جديد يلقى اقبالا من
الناس كان هذا الشيء هو ذا نوزت الذي
تعاونت فيه الشقيقتان عملت اليكس على
الجانب الفني فيما تولى الدانيلا الجانب
التسويقي وفي عام 2015 انطلقت تطبيق
الجديد الذي كان عباره عن رساله اخباريه
بمحتوى اعلامي في مجالات الثقافه والصحه
والجمال والعمل وغيرها من المضامين التي
تهم المراه واجهت دانيلا في البدايه
تحديات كثيره فهي لا تملك خلفيات اعلاميه
او اي خبرات بالكتابه والصحافه فتلقت ردود
فعل محبطه قبل ان تعمل على تطوير مهاراتها
الكتابيه خلال الشهور السته الاولى قامت
دانيلا بكتابه كامل المحتوى بنفسها وعملت
على تسويق تطبيقها من خلال صفحات التواصل
الاجتماعي قبل ان تبني قاعده مشتركين جيده
وتبدا بجني الارباح التي ساعدتها في توظيف
عدد من المتدربين لمساعدتها
استفادت دانييل من تخصصها الدراسي في مجال
رياده الاعمال في جامعه بوسطن لتنجح في
انشاء شركتها الخاصه ورغم انها لم تجد
وقتا للراحه بين العمل والدراسه الا انها
نجحت بعد اربع سنوات من بدء التطبيق
الجديد بجمع 500 الف مشترك وما معدله
اربعه ملايين مشاهده شهريا
تخرجها بدات دانيلا تطلب الاعلانات
فارتفعت ايراداتها من مليون دولار في عام
2019 الى سبعه ملايين دولار في عام 2020
ثم الى اربعين مليون دولار في عام 2021
حيث نجحت في الحصول على شراكات ومعلنين
مثل بامبل وفيديلتي وتويتر
مع الوقت طورت دانيلا كثيرا من محتواها
الاعلامي وباتت رسالتها الاخباريه
المجانيه تمزج الاخبار والروابط مع مقالات
الموضه والتجميل وغيرهما وباعت حصه صغيره
من الشركه التي تتشارك فيها مع والدتها
الى مستثمر بقيمه 200 مليون دولار وكانت
هذه اول اموال خارجيه تحصل عليها الى جانب
قرض قيمته 15 الف دولار من والديها قامت
بتسديده كما اطلقت منصه تحريريه جديده
لمتجر دين فونبرغ العالمي تحت اسم ذوي
كليراب
بالكثير من المشكلات الصحيه خلال مسيره
حياتها فبالاضافه الى معاناتها من اضطراب
الحركه ونقص الانتباه عاش التجارب صعبه
لتخطي اضطرابات نفسيه اخرى كالوسواس
القهري والاكتئاب لكنها في النهايه نجحت
في تحصيل الامتياز الجامعي وجمع الثروه
تقدر ب 220 مليون دولار كما تعد ثاني اكثر
شابات امريكا العصاميات بعد كايلي جينر
كما ان امامها الكثير من الافاق لتواصل
مسيرتها الناجحه